the Joe Rogan experience I still
remember dog being a [ __ ] kid on a
Saturday and watching doom come Kim and
Mancini kick a [ __ ] out of each other
cuz that was live on
I was lobby see barbells were absolutely
yeah duck cooked him those the reason
why they changed the the round number
from 15 down to 12 after that guy died
what was that again this was easy
it looks like it's outside doesn't it
yeah it is outside outside yeah that's
crazy Tim Ryan this had to be January or
February of 83
dude this is a crazy number 82 like two
months for that November of 82 Mancini
was an animal never we fought Alexis
argüello I think that's this right here
he huh
the Korean guy do kind of Ken God rest
his soul wrote on a piece of wood before
you went out to fight and kill or be
killed
yeah that guy was a tough [ __ ] a
boom boom Mancini but the top
[ __ ] this was 1979 he was 21
years old is this a duck who Kim fight
so imagine he killed somebody when he
was 21 years old in a fight that is
hardcore man probably both things and
then also probably probably how to make
weight a lot of deaths in boxing
apparently happened in the lower weight
classes and one of the reasons is that
when these guys actually enter into
fights a lot of times they're still
dehydrated they would dehydrate themself
pretty bad in the weigh-ins to get to
whatever weight class it was like 134
but he probably weighs you know 134 and
a quarter is what he waited and he
probably walks around like 150 ish or
something like that and they dehydrate
themselves it's very difficult to
rehydrate the brain apparently it's not
as quick and easy as it is rehydrating
the body and even that takes some time
so most of the deaths in boxing have
occurred most of them is still very
dangerous even for the heavyweight
division there was a guy who went into a
coma Russian guy in a fight a few years
back
but in the lighter weight divisions they
think it's generally when people get
more more more likely to die from fights
and they think it might have something
to do with cutting weight but it's also
like you know really skillful people
punch each other in the head the Gerald
McClellan fight is a good example that
they always point to because general
McClellan who was just a straight-up
murderer when he was a light heavyweight
really struggled to make weight man real
bad and in one fight with Nigel Benn
Nigel Benn got off the deck and it
looked like he was out and made it back
into the ring fought his ass off and
then started taking it to Gerald but
this don't come Kim right here again
yeah and that was the end of the fight
after ray Mancini stopped him
everybody's all happy then the guy
slides into a coma my ends up dying see
he's sitting there like so he's he's
really battered they think again I think
it might have something to do with
cutting weight it's a [ __ ] horrible
horrible way to go man but kill or be
killed that's what he signed up for
doctor he wrote before yeah I mean he
fought that way too
[Applause]